I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense the thing in my life that
shifted the most that kind of affected
me more than anything was actually it
was only six weeks or so but at that
time in the Darfur doing the relief work
because it was what led me to the
military and I was completely lost so
how old were you when you went to Darfur
I was 23 okay so I got out of I got it
graduated high school thought I want to
be a firefighter went to fire fighters
cool down San Diego it wasn't that I
didn't want to be a firefighter I just
wasn't really ready to grow up I think
it was a very like you know you gotta
take that serious boys just take a lot
longer than girls it's okay that's true
that's very true I'm still working and
then I started working on a fishing boat
down there just to make money and I
loved it it was pretty good money for an
18 year old kid so I did that for like a
year and I moved up here and you know
odd jobs and then 9/11 happened and I
started thinking about the military but
still didn't join right away cuz I just
wasn't sure what I would do and I didn't
I just didn't know if I could handle it
I didn't believe myself at that time I
was a very different person oh really
yeah just hard on myself and yeah you
know just I don't know insecure whatever
okay it was just like that was my
hardest face and some kids it's younger
like you said boys mature slow for me
like my early twenties were not a good
there's a dark time hmm and and I read
about what was going on in the Darfur
the genocide in a Time magazine article
and I just I didn't I wasn't leaving
anything important back here so I
decided to just go over there and figure
it out and I got there talked my way
onto a UN flight and got out to the
refugee camps and volunteered for like
six weeks you snuck out there is that
right like so worried about that because
people are trying to probably get out
and you're trying to get in well I
wanted to go with like Doctors Without
Borders or one of those organizations
and I called them all but because I
didn't have a college degree and it was
like six months of red tape and I don't
know some kind of training stuff they
wouldn't let me go but I was like you
were more ready I was ready and I was
like
reading about how you're understaffed
and camps like you need people and I'm
like I'll do anything else it's like
people having to pay for dogs at the at
the shelter or adopting a child it's
like these these animals and children
need homes why are you making it hard
right right right yeah that's what it
that's what it felt like for sure but
it's just showing up there helps though
I mean there was a few people that were
like I mean people thought I was in the
CIA I got like interrogated all this
crazy stuff I didn't have anything but
after I got shared with him while I was
there and like look I just I need a
purpose you know and I feel like this is
it right now huh and they let me let me
help and it completely changed me just
spending the time with those people but
also like I developed this this
patriotism that I didn't really have
while I was there about my country
mm-hm just because I was so grateful for
what we had your heartily and and also I
was like thinking about you know in
history the United States has often
stood up for other countries for people
that can't fight for themselves like
these people mm-hmm
and I came back from England after
living there for three years and racing
definitely not like you know saving
lives or anything and I got an American
flag checkered flag tattoo because I was
like I wasn't like I don't like other
countries but I was like America is
pretty great
it is pretty great it's maybe the maybe
the best probably the best
[Music]